all right what's wrong with you dude hey
but nothing's wrong with me the report
says the potty on Monday yep Bahamas
Baja Gracie month everything puts a
shirt off take sure laughter why you
don't train a god I'm taking this off
only details take it off I'm not taking
out because you're telling - yes you are
take it off now listen you don't you
know better and I want to eat some
Korean noodles well I'm drinking the
some teenage with c'mon I'm not sure
take that jiu-jitsu sweatshirt take off
my sweatshirt that I've earned never and
I want to take it I just rained take it
off when I take both of you oh that
noise don't make that no I I will [ __ ]
I almost gotten to mix up with you
yesterday cuz we had some mats and I
didn't want to do in front your friend I
don't care about my new friend I went no
snow is you with you [ __ ] nose
the nose I had my shoes off he kept
saying we're nose no yaar we're on your
friend Jeff went you're definitely not
nose to note in case you're not me by a
nose hair and you're not six-foot I am
[ __ ] so close six feet that you should
just 510 courtesy of 510 no I'm not
don't say Papa you have a tape measure
we do whoo all right you ready yeah I'm
gonna do it my shoes off sure about time
yeah but you do mind you start this you
don't mind - yeah I'd like today take
the sweatshirt off before we do anything
else I don't want you embarrassing
I was literally gonna take it off yep
because I'm hot the only reason I'm
taking this off take it off the only
reason I ever get on this Rach feel
better no take it off y'all gonna take
it off it's because I'm has your big
logo on the back yeah take it off and
I'll take it off when I want and if you
don't think that I flatten my neck out
just a little bit when I walk by guys in
this I'm sure
yeah because my neck the bright thing
sango's they're ever in my neck I can do
I can transition from a triangle to an
armbar to a like you an omoplata
are you kidding me right now death are
you serious not a blue belt I am a hoop
out I'm a core I'm a hand so gray so
really how many years ago is that I'm
not in a [ __ ] I don't count to over
20 over talking a lot dude I do
why do you say 20 yard that's for the
other Bluebell that's a [ __ ] district
I stood on 20 rail head not the magnet
at street sports for a long time ones
right ones last time you saw hens are
gracing rolled
the last time I rolled was literally two
months ago
no I'm saying with hens Oh Gracie Hansol
Hansol just give me a year hand so is in
my heart
yep I always carry to my hearty - I love
him though okay so how long I heart give
me like estimate I mean are we talking
telepathically because I watch his
videos I know I hear you yeah physical
running train it is Academy I am a cyber
student of hands for grace yes I get
that yeah last time you were there gun
blasts mom's great studio that's gonna
be at the studio physically in the
studio if you had to get out Sarah may
or may not have been a brown belt here's
the thing 1990 look it was probably mm
or maybe 99 yeah take it off don't
[ __ ] say that cuz I want a surf and
turf and I really do do you know how
Serpentor I really do
now or just gonna do I I tweaked my
lower back on this left side not afraid
don't give a [ __ ] anyway I'll still go
this whiskey so nice the whiskey ah she
calms me down so you're lucky you lucky
in that nice we're gonna have another
match and we ready we're gonna do it and
we're we're in that space it hey B I
know you see me on them trails dude yeah
everybody's like how are you going so
fast all the time you just started
mountain biking yeah that's right well I
get a secret I might have endurance you
have endurance where do you get your
endurance before they people go are you
Lance thick strong right is that what's
going on here hands thick strong shout
what's going on I know you're on EPO and
I go and they're like well you're not
doing EPO what could you be Marni I'm
doing beat elite before and after
workouts man beat a leap before my
workout helps my endurance improves my
energy stamina promotes oxygen
efficiency which is what I need on them
sweat way I don't care about it's
delicious when you drink it's pretty
cool eight though you know yeah and
easily distrust by hundreds professional
teams and elite athletes so you know
you're getting top-notch performance
from beat elite do what we do man take
this game to the next level especially
thick boy bike club members with beat
elite by going to live human coms last
fire that's Li ve
human calm
Jim quieter I just did 20% team that
human is making this offer exclusive to
the tea fat K army you won't find the
deal like this anywhere else that's live
hu ma n comms last fight or live human
live yeah I say live yeah do in same
spelt the same way long coming to that
human or live live human dot-com slash
fighter writer maybe I'll be gonna ship
these nuts in your mouth I'm not but if
you're gonna do it you better do it fast
why because one way to do it there's
only one what you want to do listen
whatever you're selling with you're
sending nuts to your mom whatever you're
doing you selling stuff online yo get
your orders out fast yeah you ship
station man you need ship station calm
it's the fastest easiest most affordable
way to imagine ship your orders a few
clicks
dude you're managing yours print out
labels get orders that quickly you save
money on shipping costs and you keep
customers happy okay so it doesn't
matter no matter where you're selling
Amazon at sea your own website ship
station brings all your orders into one
simple interface and making them really
easy to manage from any device get this
ready even yourself dude you nailed it
brah ship station works with all the
major carriers including USPS FedEx UPS
even Amazon alright
no wonder ship stations number one
choice of online sellers and right now
the final kid listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
the code fighter make sure your business
is ready to meet the demands of delivery
culture get started at ship station
dot-com today tell him how to do it
Brian click the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type fighter fighter
that's ship station calm then offer code
fighter ship station comm make ship
happen you and I do their mobile you
have access to Matt's yeah you took your
time say this you know what about you
know better I'll put it back nope kid
you be really hot if you didn't listen
me look at me we're gonna go take downs
where I have room sure and I know you're
gonna do that stupid [ __ ] double leg
but I see it coming
no won't do a double leg good oh good
luck that what do you do hip toss me
good [ __ ] dope single leg single leg
on me we dude I'll clear this out right
now keep talking [ __ ] and take you down
listenmi listenmi I'm telling you I
don't have room to move here did we do I
have room and I'm bigger but I don't
have I'm gonna move this and I'm gonna
take you down I don't have room to move
dude I'm telling my if you talking chill
it's gonna happen on Monday what it's
gonna happen on Monday what's gonna
happen on today's Monday but yeah I'm
not afraid I this is I don't give a [ __ ]
Monday to me now listen listen up
measure me
okay I'm gonna measure me all right and
then watching I need you to watch your
movement Q's watch your movement I need
you to watches right now right now we're
on turf I know that how do you keep this
attitude up we're gonna get on sir I
don't know that you could I don't you're
gonna go you're gonna go single leg tell
me how you want me to take you down pick
up take them you're gonna go single I
got me what would you like I mean you
want up you are what you want a trip
you're gonna have my trip nice with full
I know let's measure I know you're
strong sure let's measure you and then
see what happens
my single legs as good as your single in
my single leg defense all [ __ ] aside
it'll surprise you here's here's the
thing B it's Monday yeah it's Monday I
have a little whiskey me I've had a full
bag of candy so here's the thing you had
a full bag and I have nicotine in my
look here's the thing dude so you're
under the influence right now not really
we're gonna move this table I'll let you
start with a however deep you want to
get on a single leg and we'll see how it
goes for you yeah and what do you gonna
do
wait hold on I'm not trying to get a
single leg on you jack
why not you just said you were getting a
single eye on me sure which I'll try to
give you an advantage which all right
well you I gotta measure me all right
let's see what happens no thank you I
don't like you shoes now cuz you look
way taller than you suppose wait on
because with your shoes off we're we're
here take your shoes off
no here I got stand on this part
watch this Jack from the hill stand up
on this can't drop your heel huh hold on
let me get my [ __ ] self Khan yeah
you're right above were you right at 511
hold on let's get off your bike you're
right at Woollett I'm gonna market where
you are there you go
511 and change 511 change
511 change far from 600 so I got that's
all of this so 71 inches yep
you send me one inches see what 71 is so
you show you about me and Shawn from six
foot anyone it chooses right about five
and a half all right you [ __ ] up on
Monday this is I don't give a [ __ ] month
it is or not
what's up dude no just everybody
everybody calm the [ __ ] down your dad
we're good right we're good mama see
traffic runs up your wrist I want to sit
on this table are we doing good take
your shirt off all right I don't have
the game point of that all right hey
sorry like a little tense right now just
a little tense cuz we don't we don't
really [ __ ] you know things that do
it to you
we got some quarantine I got
testosterone is can you imagine when I
go on test what is gonna happen your
face well let's get a happen to your
hair that's not cold it makes you more
bald you know that that's the problem
that's the other reason that I want to
contest on I mean but I get sore and it
takes me a while to recover
I know testosterone can help with that I
think right I guess so can human growth
so can [ __ ] it up takes a while to work
the thing but also testosterone your
hair just you know what the problem with
test and anavar and human growth for a
guy like Brian what you'd be so a thin
man yeah you'd be you'd be a thick thick
shredded think I'm a thicker how many
inches were you by 71 what that makes
sense
no no no if I've done okay your Tom
Cruise I'm not fine concrete 511 your
chunker's let's see maybe you're 72 no
70 okay you were 71 and then some right
he's 71 and a half there you go no
that's what it is dude those are numbers
Brian it's right here [ __ ] by who
you're not 511 five nine you're Tom
Cruise you can't do it that way like
that doesn't work that way it takes up
to it's that's fake you have to do a
freeman heel dude how have chin do it or
can't do it you can't do it yourself you
did yourself dating Brian fake news
you know it's disappointing us how hard
is for you to hold that down I'm use a
no not in front has to be in the back
from the front or side it'll make them
6-1 don't lift your head up Brian
keep it straight you're going high
right there right nope right there I'm
just telling you I think that's a good
I told you my [ __ ] god no way that's
what that ruler says but this yeah well
then there you go
you are definitely taller dude you know
seven 1.5 inches equals five nine and a
half that's cool no big deal
you're small guy dude I'm not you're a
smaller man you're smaller guy small guy
that's why I can make you take off your
sweatshirt did I have the heart of a
lion sure sure yeah and I'm 511
officially that's a weird measurement
[ __ ] thing out of here yeah I know
what doctor did you go to wait and why
did you go to the doctor you didn't go
recently they're not open what is that
what is this that's Korean spicy chicken
noodles a lot of people do this online
is it the chicken noodle spicy no
challenge what's your challenge it's
super hot it's very spicy
you made it cut yeah this is the bag of
ramen that Qin brought last week Oh guys
no disrespect you know I love you Kat if
I ate that I would [ __ ] my pants you bar
I can handle spicy though right yeah of
course
is it does need to be wound up but he's
good no you're good all right cool take
that to the dome right now be let's see
straight to the dome he's just one awful
in yeah suck it in suck it in then wash
it down whiskey hold on
hey you know you should use chew into
the mic that's fun sounds good oh you
like it
Papa like pop pop just pop a lover know
why just so hot cat what's in it the
seasoning this is stuff you love Jen I
love it but it's so hard to get through
for me but a lot yeah cuz yeah it's
tough for me try some ring I'm just not
in the space to try it
are you 19 I've had candy I've had Brian
like that this is my second americano
I've had whiskey very nice
I had chicken tortilla soup I'll tell
you what happens in the hot sauce daddy
doesn't get weight
daddy wipe your lips when Daddy your
lips are red daddy I'm pop-up Thanks
when Papa eats bread daddy your fear oh
cool your honorable man
hey daddy your feet your uncle man what
about my feet dude like you're out good
I got long toes I can throw on the
[ __ ] animal light with my feet
now now daddy I mean we're playing
dodgeball yesterday yeah you're a little
impressed Maya it's not bad how about
Steven's arm my brother wall can [ __ ]
slang play college baseball that guy
could throw it those balls are not
painful but if he'd hit you in the face
with that speed
Nubian how about our boy Jeff and my son
the face right yeah right now tell us
honest Tigers not happy stamped his foot
he's not happy
and then he tackled Jeff yeah no sucks I
feel that yeah my mouth is on fire is it
that hot sure my mouth is on fire and
but she'd never know what would me well
okay just dug into that though yeah no
we're drinking the 17 year old whiskey
bubble I'll tell you something at night
is the Robbie what at night I get lonely
I get a little anxious and I start
drinking yeah and I eat Sarge active
Hokies and they eat cookies ice cream
sandwiches I just [ __ ] I would never do
does the quarantine yeah yeah then I
wake up a little anxious in the middle
of the night really how often you wake
up in the middle of night very rare
really very rare Oh
every now and then I do but very rare do
you have time if I'm sleeping by myself
and the kids in the house I can't see
wake up just like you do just worried
all the time now do you not eat before
you go to bed what do you see I see I
put tell you about seven so I eat around
7:30 and that's
I don't eat again till around 11:00 or
12:00 that's my problem is I'm eating
too lately I like 9ya [ __ ] me up I wake
up like especially at your age you know
most older men when they have heart
attacks yeah the the usually the common
factors they had like a big like steak
dinner is that true yeah a hundred
percent believe that like do they had a
big dinner right before that our tech
100% believe that because I wake up if I
drank wine is steak I'm like sweating
and my heart's beating on him daddy has
to be careful yeah I'm getting older
Ginola
pretty good at dodgeball though yeah my
arm is okay I can throw I was there I
was always able to throw kind of fast I
should be able to throw way faster and
then since all the years my shoulders
yeah tough this big what I should always
be able to throw punches yeah mr.
shoulders are tight super tight yeah
super tighten
if tight shoulders did you do you watch
that Jordan documentary last night not
yet you'd love that I know I would
that's why I'm wearing these essentially
join one what did you get for it what
what um what did you get from it well
you forget how great Jordan was like
Michael Michael are magic Johnson posted
thing did everybody posted the CIO's ie
is it's good for the younger generation
to see how great Michael Jordan was why
is the best play of all time where the
body forget yeah oh yeah oh just
ridiculous then the debate this morning
on first take and on wakeup is uh you
know who's better LeBron James or Jordan
what would you say I think it I think it
all depends where you like what
generation you grew up and you know so
Jordan in my house well I would say the
way to ask the question it's a weird
question cuz it's different you out
having your team if you had to choose
might be that way but but it's out it's
it's tough though cos no one can really
guard Jordan I'm sorry I know what Noah
can guard Jordan no one can guard LeBron
and then it's like Jordan was more
clutch who makes their team better
that's really might be the question you
know what the thing is with Jordan
Jordan said this about documentary goes
the thing about this documentaries and
once it's all out everyone watches it he
goes people are gonna think I'm an
[ __ ] she's using the torso a known
for being an [ __ ] like he punched
Steve Kerr in the face it was a teammate
because he wasn't playing right he did
punch
in the face what he was just very
difficult and they they have him on
there like talking [ __ ] to teammates
during practice
you just expect a lot he was like Kobe
Co he's the same way yeah this is the
exact like Dwight Howard
it's like Kobe hated Dwight Howard he's
in all this potential he was lazy yeah
so they hate them they have these
resentments against them so Jordan was
very similar so he came out goes the
problem to stock commentary's people
gonna find I was an [ __ ]
yeah and he's an employee if you know
anything about Jordan I've had her
hoarsely known for being shy Nestle I
mean all due respect he I his Hall of
Fame speech well yeah
tough you know it was like man this guy
doesn't forget any slight and that
that's why like when they're they're
going back on like 85 84 85 they're
talking about games high school games
college games you would an out in and
he's going through his first and second
year in the NBA and then 97 96 is time
the NBA
I don't know I'm assuming they're going
hey do you remember this this and the
refreshing his memory because there's no
way he remembers those details like that
and he said yes I don't know if he does
that's what I'm saying I wonder if he
has helped or because we asked me about
my career and you go back to camps and
just sparring this like [ __ ] it'd be
tough to follow all that like he follows
but say you're a little bit different
only because I feel like you in sports
as good as you were and as dedicated you
were your mentality has always been once
it's over you're moving on to the next
Lea and more than almost anybody I know
who know so it's not that you know like
it's not I know you love the people you
train with you just don't keep in touch
with people from your past because
you're just so focused on the frontier
that yeah yeah and so I'm a little bit
like that to my past like my friend once
I said I know nothing about your
childhood well I don't really talk about
it because I doesn't matter
I'm too busy thinking about what's next
that's good and it's bad it is what it
is I don't know I don't know what it is
but well like my brother remind me of
stuff like last night right when we got
done playing at that place I get in the
car I look at my phone cousin look at my
phone all day oh yeah my phone into this
I have a notice from Nike saying they
dropped these Jordans because of the
dots the Jordan fives and my brother
goes remember these are the first
drawings we ever had mom
first and then all the mint like if so
just does that then all the measure yep
but I do that something I looked at amaz
like oh I remember like I remember going
I never had those but then I don't
remember all the details and J was
telling me about like holy [ __ ] I
remember that yeah yeah and until
somebody reminds you of that stuff it's
true is that you guys know oh my god
that's you I was on the front cover of
Denver Post wait is that your dad yep
also known as your mom oh really my dad
was the ruler my dad was your mom was
such a dime piece my stepmom okay she
was beautiful monoliths in the show she
will [ __ ] you up your mom's beautiful
your mom stepmom is a dime piece dime
piece yeah my dad though junior of Iraq
Jay was Jay was David planning and you
both well hold on Jay was old long neck
with the dirt mustache he sure was long
that key was much bigger than you dude
oh and then you grew I love you Sarah I
don't know not that old what a great dad
your dad was a beast of a dead great dad
he's a great guy he couldn't look more
he is Saddam Hussein in that picture so
different he's a giant Iraqis you're
raised by an Iraqi only comment said one
ago said hey how many bullets is your
dad Dodge being the double body for uh
Saddam hundred percent he is I bet you
your dad you did your genome you don't
have any Arabic no there Wow I'll do you
Wow Italian that's Italian dish that's
an Italian man apparently he's from Iran
that's cool he's from it he's Iranian am
i right you're you're Iranian and and
and Lebanese your family Shania Twain so
that's cool that's right and in Jays
Pete Davidson so we're doing well we're
all doing well when did Papa now Jane
Jaden J's NEX Runk we know this right
Jay doesn't have a neck anymore so I
don't know what happened that's a long
that's a Bryan Callen Mac that's a long
neck left longer than your neck it's
long my neck that's the longest that's a
human giraffe right there and he went
from giraffe to to rhino
now how did that happen let's go ahead
and look at his neck now look at him now
yeah first team all thick he's first
team all thick
he's a thick boy
um Wow he's obsessed with now when did
Papa shave his mustache
ah cuz that's a man he had it since I
was it forever and I remember I think I
was in high school he I'm he's out a
mustache and she's a 70s guy he probably
probably married that's all bottom dude
Wow sure I remember when he shaved and I
was I was so disappointed I was like sad
as I grew up with him in a mustache 225
220 and trim 215 trim in way better
shape than always works out every single
day yeah yeah every single day he's a
he's a stunt stunt Hey what was his
sport uh he's a little bit of everything
football they lost his finger makes it
though he lost his finger you see my dad
my pop was like that he's missing this
oh no but I'll bring it up the next time
I see him do it my son does it you know
he's a four year old how do you lose his
finger uh mafia Japanese yeah yahooza he
was uh smart at the time he was uh
Denver Colorado was snow blowing the
driveway and he got stuck it froze the
ice and he forgot to turn off went oh
let me on stick it put his hand in there
so it chopped off three of them they
salvaged two of the three Wow they grow
up my Poppa were like this now and then
every time I Sun season goes he goes
grandpa grandpa Peter come grab you know
I was like for grandpa's he was grandpa
Peter you don't have a finger every time
he sees them remind them you don't have
a finger yeah my papa's like this
your son is he's about the size of the
average 14 year old now and that's
because fans are I couldn't leave our
biggest hands what I know is hands him I
said it three times I was like glued his
hands you about how about yesterday
yesterday at the the place where he
played my son's potty-trained right he
doesn't diapers anymore he's great I
hope we've had no accents had done peed
the bed don't pee his pants the butt
poopy no problems yesterday he's playing
all day three hours run it and sweating
drifts with sweat I see him go to the
bathroom in my hand like I tried going
there I'm like yeah he's good I'm
talking to someone I think it's talking
to you and another buddy so he goes and
I'm like he gots this and then five ten
minutes later seeks out his papa and I'm
like y'all [ __ ] I walk in like a what
dude
and he looked Jarius he was Papa I had
to pee so bad and I
but I peed a little bit on my under my
underwear I go okay and he goes I don't
want the girls to know because I'm
embarrassed on with the girls no can you
imagine at four years old he's already
he understands it because I'm their bare
sight because there's no girls there and
one he's obsessed with and they're older
there are over 12 and he goes pop I'm
embarrassed I'm with the girls no I go
watch this dude I go did you pee on your
pants you guys know I go alright here's
what we'll do I'm gonna take your
underwear I'm gonna put in my pocket I'm
gonna put your pants back on
and then they'll never know don't say
things you don't say anything you know I
won't say anything you okay I go first
and you go later okay you go first and
I'll go later okay think about that you
never know and you have children that
they get embarrassed and you have to be
really careful of not embarrassed and
embarrassed I'm not sure and I would
forget with my kids and my the mother
Amanda would always say hey you're
embarrassing you're embarrassing it's
because I would I would scold them in
front of people and it's yeah because
but then it become a that becomes issues
for them and then it Pat it rears its
heart being embarrassed is there
anything worse than the feeling of
embarrassment you know I well document
and I have body morphe issues I remember
when my dad bought that Neil politan ice
cream
and it was it was strawberry chocolate
and vanilla and I hated the chocolate
and I loved the strawberry I remember I
ate all the strawberry and I was chill
on the couch like you know he work 9:00
to 4:00 worked his ass off came home
probably was
feigning some strawberry ice cream goes
in there and he goes bread because I was
always the ice cream kid he was Brandon
and I'm like I'm laying on the couch you
know this watching pretty [ __ ] I
don't know Animaniacs of some [ __ ] and
he goes you ate all the ice cream I go
I'll eat the strawberry goes god you're
fat pig good luck not like mean was like
God you fat pig but it sounds worse I'm
saying he was just saying I got the fat
pig like yeah
goddamn doing the walk dog yeah oh dude
really
Oh tattooed on the heart fat pig yeah
certainly gotta be careful certain like
yeah especially because yeah I was tough
fat pig has kind of rough all right I
was like hmm I would never say it to my
kid my
so there's that when we were in that we
were in Mykonos and this Italian girl or
she met him in French she said my sister
we were all dancing and and we got a got
on a bum pompous confidence bump a scuff
with this other group of Italian kids
and the woman called my sister a pig
nothing worse my sister who's [ __ ]
Teflon my sister goes what's she call me
and my buddy Regulus she called you a
pig my sister goes well tell her that
this pig is gonna punch her right in the
face because that's just American South
yeah and they were hearing that
nevertheless Jesus what I think I tell
her her brother a punch the guy's the
pig's brother will punch them in the
faith as pigs will [ __ ] you guys up say
you know we're pigs and we'll [ __ ] it
he's American pigs here bring it bring
human [ __ ] anywhere do certain stuff
man it just [ __ ] with you I for me
the bet the part of me I've never saw
the Sun our young Leslie tad now the
tattoo on my heart was there was this
kid Ronnie who was muscular I always
knew he in a t-shirt
he had a chest and stomach muscles just
thick kid and I remember my girlfriend
and her sisters talking about how sexy
sexy he was in a t-shirt and how it
ripples and I was there and I was like
you don't have that dude and my
girlfriend I was like first of all I was
like girls find muscles sexy didn't know
that I didn't I was too young I was 14
or 13 really well didn't autonomy well I
remember I didn't have muscles so girls
like me yeah but they're like me for
something else yeah so I was like you'd
go I was like oh no I I don't have I
don't rip all under a t-shirt no I'm
skinny that was the worst I never forgot
it though those certain things that like
[ __ ] burn into your [ __ ] brain now
now take care of myself you know what I
mean now I'll go turf I'll go surf
whatever it is I mean I'm saying it's
still a coat hanger now I'm still
totally sure and and sinewy like a
parkour athlete do you know what I'm
saying
you guys know what the [ __ ] I'm saying
certain things out for us are this
you're never gonna ripple and I'm never
gonna be skinned be quiet fat pig
hey Pig never see you tomorrow aren't
you [ __ ] eat noodles you're fat pig
and drink some more whiskey that big
that's a rough one
well you think about how girls feel how
awful they feel about you know when this
poor mr. Naito broke my heart she didn't
make the top 20 but she she was kind of
you know she's not the cute thick
she was thick and had like a chubby face
she's this next girl can sing sing and
they go what the [ __ ]
like she sing they get and she goes this
is my first time ever singing in public
or live and she has a maze blew the
place apart Katy Perry goes this the
first time singing and she goes yeah she
goes why don't why don't you posting
videos and sing on youtuber why don't
you go place things she goes it breaks
my heart she goes because I don't look
like the other girls
oh dude that's all you got to say movie
you start crying oh man yeah I got
choked up while this poor girl I don't
know if you remember this that I do if
that was my daughter if you just put
some confident that big [ __ ] that pig
is saying yeah do you remember the movie
monster with Charlize Theron she wants
you whatever she's me and my girl that
are watching it and it's a true story by
the way it's a true story mr. Miller
murmur patty Jenkins yep she won an
Oscar for it yes and well Charlize did
and she was nominated but I'll watch
that and there's a moment where Charlize
in the movie says I've been alone since
I was 13 or something like that or I you
know and we both started crying we both
went like this we both are both are
looked over I said we just started on we
both you know some things like just one
little thing can [ __ ] yeah I didn't
get that in the circular movie I was
like oh kill her but I feel you ah [ __ ]
I did man I did cuz I knew her backstory
I knew the real life see I don't know I
I knew it apps when I watched the movie
and then I did my research on it god man
yes oh my god chill rough don't you know
she was so she was like rape and she
beaten by these John's the 13 years of
fighting back fighting back yeah 13
years old and just straight-up kill
appeal
need the money and just struggle so
she's so patty and Charlize Theron red I
think it was some crazy number like
10,000 letters that Eileen wrote to her
girlfriend from death row and they read
every one of those letters yeah that'd
be cool
yes and that's that's how they did the
research for the role and amazing I mean
and then Charlize Theron's put on I
think she had 40 pounds Oh to me to me
the greatest I'm telling you is one of
the greatest performance 100% she's a
fat pig in that she blew my mind she
looked she had she had she had [ __ ]
up she's so good and I know and they put
contacts in and she would do this thing
with her hair which was she was just
incredible she was so good in that and
we come well she looks just like her
oh my god the real one and left that's
her in the middle yeah she's so good in
that she's incredible more watch that
moving tonight yeah dude
hey fat pig I was watching and there's
gotta be something else I'm skinny what
yeah I don't know fat pigs fun it's hard
to make fun of skinny people yeah it's
true I'm pretty shredded what we gonna
say not shredded got a good body though
oh you would love this show I said watch
it it's called kings of pain is that
what it's called yeah yeah kings of pain
it's on History Channel these two bros
these two animal experts go around the
world to find that the toughest sting or
bite listen what these [ __ ] dizziness
hurt
we haven't them our boy what's the name
coyote Peterson mmm different level
these boys get an account they get a
boat constrictor put on like a thing so
it done bite their necks and they
kottkatt taught this boat constrictor in
the wild they let it [ __ ] him because
it's never been recorded on a boat
construed can do a human with their bite
and they're doing a scale one through 30
dude hey fat pig
yeah this [ __ ] snake yeah
shreds their [ __ ] arms yeah because
their teeth cobalt it bites it and they
can't get it off and they have alcohol
to dump in the snake's mouth to let go
well they doesn't let go yet to have all
these stitches look at they have a
monitor lizard bison centipede bite 70
different level than what our boy coyote
Pearson does they have the destroyer
wasp they have the bullet they have all
anything you know a big Santa peed yeah
oh dude and one of the guys gets bit and
he's like passes out right they have
medics it's crazy fast not you good show
that [ __ ] do that when that snit when
that [ __ ] snake bites them and you
can tell I'm nervous they are and they
decide who goes first
oh so they both have to do it oh dude
yikes yeah look at his arm there with
the stitches scroll down look at that
[ __ ] dad I think someone else's but
these are not still bad oh we give that
picture on the far left chin look at
that [ __ ] I've been bit by no doubt
he's fighting him yeah far left far left
yeah weird the snake sliding there look
at that dude I've been bit by a Python
that's not true yes I used to have a
little ball python no Burmese not
beyblade hey not me that's about that
fat pig never happy that pig
I had the [ __ ] scars nope no scars
[ __ ]
and I was thinking how much so the
centipede they got bit by this destroyer
wasp they got bit by scorpions the
monitor lizard and I thought when I
watch these boys are making I couldn't
find their salary but can't be much no
you can't pay more they're trying to
make a name for themselves is they're
all youtubers at a show it's a show miss
your History Channel now okay but
they're both they're both good dudes man
they're fun to watch yeah pretty well
what's next though well that's about
that they get a lion well I lost my arm
you know I want me I want him to get bit
by a rattlesnake and that's not good
because a rattlesnake can do permanent
nerve damage so you can't use your army
you want to show or not dude you know
what ratings are not that big you can
die from our pit viper you died from
from some of these other ones yeah you
fat pig I know this you definitely say
to me do I call you fat pig that hurts
your heart a little no did your heart
okay uh-huh doesn't bother me anyway my
skin's thick now my dad called me now
what I told you when I was in the pool
you know houses built rich and well
we're in the pool might get full-sized
Olympic pool yeah hot tub best well
anyways full court in it so we're in the
pool my dad goes just Alicia goes you're
still working out Oh a lot guy I went
you know I am he is huh and they just
went and played with my son like swam
off that's so wrong huh
ah [ __ ] man I know that was like two
months ago I've been working out more
than I've ever worked out and I don't
nothing grows nothing is what I mean
either I mean to do that I read I wrote
10 miles on my [ __ ] bike this is a
big boys bike club Wow it's a movement
yeah worldwide movement
you're welcome movement can't be part of
it mundo don't say anymore man it's
making me mad a worldwide worldwide mr.
robot right fine Moo hey all right all
over the place boy bike we Ryan in every
city it's a huge mess insanely jerseys
and stick and wombats everybody you guys
are a group you know [ __ ] bikers so
many of us oh look at you responding
okay and I'm sick of you biking well
you're posting a [ __ ] picture of your
stupid bike dude stupid you think the
specialized Stumpjumper stupid what is
it that pig is how do you fat [ __ ]
pig through the next picture how are you
on that stupid little seat look at your
face look at me dude man you got all you
got a lot of meat on your face react I
do have a lot of meat so happy you're
the next ones your lips dude bassy ten
miles look at that hey Matt speed your
fat pig at 40 miles an hour all right
but listen 39b
listen this daddy's moving I know but
like it's a movement it's a movement so
annoying do you want me to be part of it
you can't hey asking you you're looking
at the I'm the i'ma under a chassis and
don't be [ __ ] them yeah that's not
gonna be shitty okay don't be shitty
Brad me your best pitch to get it first
of all hey let me just ask you this do
we have couple requirement yeah do you
have a mountain bike now I don't know
hold on hold on not looking good
I want to buy a Stumpjumper you want a
specialized thumb job now I would avoid
6161
that that's the extra large now they're
not giving that away right expensive or
not too bad but I don't know what your
budget is what would be a good what is a
good mountain bike cost um jump my god
400 bucks bring that up do you not want
to get in the club ha is that what
you're doing $400
your bike's gonna fall apart
let me see what this bet that's
expensive you think is the game papa
okay I don't know I don't know do you
think I can be the leader of the thick
boy
look let me like Climie get a let me
California chapter and you think we have
a formula I got a starter bike and I go
grab myself with a little special like
this starter one may get a regular
mountain bike and then let me join them
hundred dollars I'll start start lifting
and start working out I'll eat more let
me be in the thick where were you on a
bike how you up hills not asking that I
got the heart of a lion not asking that
how am i up hills yes cross-country
trail I'm strong like don't worry about
me did you go to mountain yeah these new
trail I wouldn't worry about me I'll
hang I'll hang that's a video there we
go stroll down oh no don't go to stump
jumpers - is too advanced for Brian uh
you know what I like for Brian oh god I
wish do the Rockhopper now scroll down
and how much is the Rockhopper for the
old man just maybe just type in
specialized rock opera cuz this is just
the hair thing so you can shop it yeah
now I'm gonna take you to wheel world
where I got mine real world will world
die it's about bad I'm in business I'm
in business
dude between five and seven bucks we're
boys fifty we can get you on the
mountain all right here uh front where I
go yeah it's me a rough ride for it
rough ride rough ride we got some rocks
and Hills fat pig I'm telling to be a
little walking now there's a pink one
well let's not pee maybe I'll get the
door maybe I'll get sick boy on my
[ __ ] bike know what what I'm asking
dude you're barking up the tree and you
know fat pig didn't come down on the
[ __ ] you up keep talking this [ __ ] dude
hold on man
there's a lot of thick boys out there I
am birthday and we're pretty United and
I don't like the way you are it man
I'm just saying I want it let me let me
buck in here you can buck in yeah you
can buck it hey guys what you up to let
me hey guys I'll wear my thick boy
sweatshirt what's going on now we think
boy by club stickers coming out that you
put on your bike now keep this in mind
no I'm gonna charge extra
you're not thick 3% search a hole I keep
this in mind Jack
you guys are all thick you call Jackson
I'm built for mountain biking so if I
can if I pull ahead it's gonna be
humiliating if I leave the thick pack
behind fact if I'm trailing a bunch of
fat here's the thing here's the thing
fat pay if I'm like come on fat pigs
look cool I wouldn't say I'm just saying
I mean thick boys dude uh oh I want to
build my bike so you see that flapping
you see that those are electric bike
that's a note which is that one for 13
grand now am I eventually gonna get that
yeah I am brown hold on Brandon why are
you gonna get an Electra it's an
electric bike you can go further
Oh take it easy see this is the problem
with you you get all crazy over that's
the gt2 RS a bite ah so annoying you're
gonna do it on to you I know you're
gonna get out the NS works the turbo
levo SL you shave your feet that does it
corn I don't know there's not defeat the
purpose
that doesn't make you rock hard copy not
really dude because I don't know why it
doesn't it defeat the purpose of you
know now hold on you can't just dismiss
me now how's the shock on that boy that
thing is [ __ ] suck dude that bike
frustrates me but I know think dude papa
yeah well I'm going up the mountain the
other day yeah 10 miles in yeah it's
exhausting yeah funds going downhill
yeah now my leg feel a little tired
sometimes my fat ass my thick ass that
pig has to jump off the bike and walk up
the hill boy they can't bike up okay
it's so steep yeah but if Papa has some
help now you go I can stay on the bike
and cruise up and I can go farther and
farther and farther so instead of 10
miles I'm doing 30 40 miles yeah so I'm
burning more calories oh yeah I like the
bike hey don't think you're going to
workout in that dough right oh dude yes
you get sad it's only assisting you to
stay on the bike to go up the hills okay
you gonna sit so you you can do it and
leave it on but most Peters having a
system so he can stay on the by 13 grand
hey hey hey I hate to do this what oh I
hate to do this Baba
Matt you dude we'll call it even after
you remember when you're stealing all
that money for me for four years but we
didn't know wasn't your fault
either I want that in the record fine
didn't know he was stealing all that
money sure I
hey to go back all the years and recoup
that my uh hold on now hold on
all I'm asking ya buy me that by hey hey
man that's not cool you said it was a
live deal that's a [ __ ] big chunk of
change do I gonna make 26 grand or four
to $13,000 Mike dude I hate to be shitty
why if you don't buy me that bike and
your high lawyer what route you want to
go down look do this come on
right we're partners give me the bike I
you can't just ask for a $13,000 bike so
casually I'm asking for it give chin you
Craig good chin order it what you're not
ready you said you're gonna get it there
you have to get a little better on the
mechanical bike from the heaven that
sells it Excel all right that's a car
would you Dave chin stop doing this man
junior car uh-huh the whole chain no
good two attacks that's got to be at
least 15 grand now I gotta make 30 grand
dude you want pay back the money hey
we're yours hey let it go I'm going to
for 15 grand come on man
see I drank last night now I'm drinking
I'm coming with you last night
yeah I don't drink it I only drink that
in the studio only here I just only
drink let's do a stand-up I broke into
the 23 year old dick out mmm God 23 old
whiskey I'll tell you what that's 49 so
we're right over 15 taxes $1,300 yeah
dude [ __ ] it's a beautiful now odds all
odds of beating that bike for the end of
the year I don't know dude because I'm
think about my brother coming out he
needs a bike maybe you can use the
Stumpjumper I get this you're looking
for any excuse any I know the problem
with you is I know you're gonna get it
because once it goes once it's in there
it can't get it out you my promise once
it's in there it will never leave till
it's accomplished now here's the thing
you have the fastest car on the road
correct and fastest lap on the
nürnberg my guess is you're a little use
are you sick of it
are you bored with it Kenny enough of it
now I do like two other flavors I'm
always gonna pick that car you'll always
keep that car what I admire about that
is that is too
people should know this it's literally
his his only it's his driving machine he
drives it everywhere put four thousand
miles on it
four thousand miles most people have a
car like that they take it out on Sunday
for 20 minutes I bought it with 200
miles you bought it brand new 200 miles
and that's unbelievable so you ride it
you and you drive it like it's your
regular car ride it like Porsche give to
it try and wreck it and you open it up
every day now this does grazie thing is
you can still sell it for just as much
as you bought if I'm never going to I'm
gonna have to the collection now I hate
to go back to this yeah you gotta buy me
that bike okay hold on we'll get to that
in a second okay what other bite what
are the car are you thinking about
I want to McLaren 720's in all black
I want to fry pista I want a 2001 gt40
Ford Jesus
I'd like Bentley another lot of cars - I
can't oh yeah I'll get there
yeah gt40 is what I want where's that in
black
I like the red with the yellow stripes
do but the blacks a little more that's
it right there that thing sounds like a
[ __ ] there it is 236 not terrible for
that car nothing's Iman's 236,000 yes
for that car yeah I should say 236 and
you should know we're talking about
thousand yeah if you're in the same if
you're playing the same game as me now I
say 230 see that a straight away car is
that because you want to have something
that you can open up it's complete
railroad it's stick daddy nod and a
gallon that's the new one I don't like
the new ones all the computers and [ __ ]
I want the stick you want the old one I
want the old ones bad now that movie
came out with uh yeah did you see it now
Jase it's great movie haven't seen it
yet those are so sick
American yeah it's amazing how cars do
is zero for me it's like a gay man
looking at a beautiful woman really yeah
you just don't don't want on the 10th
no sucked at it no you want to get in
and drive it you only want to eat around
for me I'm like I'm saying
a lot of gay men can be around a
gorgeous naked woman and be like these
shoes look great on you and not notice
you have a lot of gay men like I would
eat her ass and when you see look at
that card you go I would drive that I
would drive it around you out do you I
could get your deal right now in a 911
Targa really you could yeah that's my
they just offer it to me my boy Greg
just was like what do you think this no
it's stick you know I like stick really
yes I do I think a poor should be stick
that's what we're talking about that's
the [ __ ] car now is it is it a
convertible
it's a Targa so you can it can be
convertible or just a t-top that's a
pretty cool car oh dude and it's in
gunmetal it's it's gone metal grey oh
hold on it's it's uh it's like
battleship grey yeah I think they call
it uh narco gray so how many miles on it
not many hmm don't waste my time though
you know
well maybe I'll look at it maybe I'll
test-drive it maybe I'll have a Porsche
we'll sit up for you yeah not do
anything Dubai Tobago that's a nice
looking car
it's I've actually all should secretly
kind of wanted a Porsche like that
that's it right there they're great cars
well some would say the best yeah the
best and hold their value huh oh yeah
it'd just be my it could be my good
father a driver far-right one that's it
that's it that's the colour that's a
beautiful color
that's great [ __ ] it has houndstooth
seats is that it what is it what are
houndstooth it's like a print oh you
know man it's too much dive into its
like me it's like you know trying to
explain nuclear physics somebody doesn't
have [ __ ] now I'm 53 in a Porsche what a
great time to have a Porsche probably
right yeah good Tesla yeah yesterday
we're by what's called almost hit stock
X X space yes base X yes
Tesla's plate John the place is not it's
not as you can see the tube that is
building goes all the way down I know
it's so cool-looking I know it's crazy
he's a visionary you guys were there oh
yeah there yesterday little test-drive
of the time don't don't worry why we're
over
you're welcome your freedom chin you're
welcome
don't worry why we're over there nuts on
a Sunday what were we doing there who
knows who knows we were busy tell you
that much
we was busy tell them that big fat pig
productions hard
that's why should name I tell many fat
pig fat my dad's Lee we know that story
I like my dad we went you'd like that
never happened I like butter pig I have
a butterscotch pig bye girls bye
how about sweet Pig sweet sweet sweet
sweet figured I a good sweet pig
production strong like a sandwich sweet
big yeah sweet Pig sweet pig BBQ butter
pig sweet pig BBQ butterscotch piggy
come on what a scotch piggy is good
butterscotch piggy is a good name for a
bar dude help you want to go this
butterscotch piggy do you want get a
butterscotch punished cup do but Scotch
piggy off for DSP come on
dude what about a thick boy bike club
coffee think boy coffee yeah that's good
car
think boy coffee I make cold brew drink
it on the road hey guy you know I never
I never do when I'm on that bike going
10 miles hot I never bring water I'd
have to have water and then I drink
those gel packs when I pee on the side
of the [ __ ] trail it comes out like
Farnese Drita ninja turtle gel really my
piss is thick well Mike of what's in
this chair are green what's in the gels
my vitamin B and [ __ ] like vitamins I
don't really know dude I should slurp it
down
I'd deep throat that thing and just
swallow the gravy the gravelord a crazy
monkey what I want take me an hour and
change but going up it takes me cuz you
cannot say 40 minutes of it's me going
uphill [ __ ] I have to get off that's a
crazy workout oh the best
Wow how'd you do it four five times a
week dude so that you're you're addicted
to going uphill or downhill the whole
thing what do you like about I love
everything about it on the freedom to
the free love it there's no I like being
out in nature in the middle of nowhere
the danger of it or what everything
rattlesnakes mountain lions I might fall
off die I get lost the rip the park
ranger maybe turn around
because I was going down dirt Mahon he
goes he goes trails closed I go my house
is that way I came this we have to kill
that whales not happening trails closed
oh god dude there's no one around no
one's get Khurana you stupid [ __ ]
so I went but I went back around waited
drove so that's why if you look at that
thing it look I know off you have to go
bad they open trails back up some trails
to help in Ventura mature County was
open and yeah the release of a lot of
the quarantine yeah I mean you know you
you remain optimistic oh yeah you're
gonna get USD fights May night other
other County not opening up May 9th you
have see fights hmm Ferg's that car tiny
person
ehe the card so staff may night where do
we know probably biggest wow I still
know audience though right nope Dana's
first team all thick to he's first team
all-sec yeah cuz Dana used to be 165 no
swear to god Steve I swear to God so
he's that shitty here well if you're
looking at when he's really young
like he's my size yes to everyone though
in it nice to be your size when I said
oh no when he was like in his 30s what
I'm there looking in there he was very
thin and then he got a little bit shred
City right went to TRT doctor there is
yeah it's look it looks awkward on
though done it didn't look real yeah
anyway that's the thing yeah it just
doesn't look natural on him no I agree
you see when he's young he's really thin
he's all front cover of Men's Fitness
just airbrushed is [ __ ] it up grill to
oh look at that bottom teeth son is that
is that Photoshop though no teeth the
roller rock there the other rough rat
yeah he talks about being 165 I can't
remember where but I was like oh yeah
you know this frame isn't he you know
here's the same body type is Jeff he now
I mean Jeremy I think that might be from
you know I don't know dude he's never
that small was he it was he did he
actually have amateur fights no cardio
kick boxing coach never had an amateur
fights I don't think so
nothing on record maybe in the gym suits
spar something like that
does it look okay good look again
Lorenzo Fertitta is a good looking guy
yeah yeah right there the other brother
you know it's not for everybody
yeah seem like good guys you know for
Tina's pretty well right are you did
there was great to me you have now she's
doing Dana White look at him
yeah hopefully that UFC goes up it says
no dude about yeah check out those guys
hey um the bonus episode with with will
was fun yeah we're digging the bonus up
Steve all right we'll have another one
now now I this and we'll tell me this he
was actually working for CNN when he
came on here and say those are facts
came on with CNN yeah in Tooele Sheamus
and that's fine
just to Sheamus Sheamus yeah even though
we're five feet apart right now wills
the government shill and it's not a big
deal not a big deal scared to leave his
house here's the boys 400-pound people's
channels champ and it believes house and
the white rock the light rock round face
white lock yep supposed to do some
current events won't cheat some more
noodles they were very hot I want to
take for it to go in okay I can't eat
the whole thing no problem yeah yeah do
it man and I'm gonna have a raspberry so
a lot of people on the Internet are
upset about Joe coming out and saying
that he's buying corona tests for all of
his guests every time they enter the
studio to do a podcast what they're
upset because they're saying that there
are a lot of people who can't get tests
done and are suffering while he can just
buy it out of his own pocket so it's
important for people to realize number
one it's so much cheaper than people
think it is $200 let's turn it on test
is like 200 and change for everybody so
well no for 1%
for him to come I think it's it's a
one-time thing right I don't think it
costs too much jeweler ologist s yeah
it's not what I heard her vez 200 hours
total because the actual ya be killed so
they came to my house yeah but they'll
test your family for 200 really yeah
he's an extravagant that's a lot of
money to her a lot of money a lot of
money but it's not extravagant it's not
here's the thing there's a number you
can call it'll come to anybody south
yeah not only that it's not like Joe
Rogan is taking a test away from it he
chose being very very responsible he
can't afford it and the reason he can
afford is cuz he's earned it because
people love his podcast it's also called
teller he's put in 10,000 hours he's put
in way more than that Joe's been also
are you enjoying his content yeah the
the pride 12 hours content content he
gives you cool that he gives you for
free cool oh you talked about the
biggest show in the world yeah and the
guy wants get tested yeah you know
initially he tests HEDIS Barry being
responsible test all his guests so he's
setting an example in that sense also
it's not his fault that not everybody
can afford that our issues with the
government yoshi's with your local yeah
you know representatives not Joe Rogan
right and Austin anyone who's upset suck
a dick right how about that right there
you go
people are also saying that I believe it
was the doctor who's administrating
these tests for Joe he came out and said
that they're doing the blood work not
the nasal passage yeah and so the same
guy so he did all of us so he pricked
your finger like you're taking a you
know blood sugar test if you have
diabetes the pretty swinger you dropped
the blood on this little thing he puts
into this little cartridge yeah and he
said that that test actually isn't FDA
approved and so he would it wouldn't
really make sense for people to be angry
about Joe taking away testing from other
people whereas if you go to the hospital
the nasal
one is actually FDA approved and that's
the one that the hospital would have to
administer not the blood test yeah
that's how I take all the way how about
this goes every test program pays for
including the ones that that his guests
take should he instead use that money to
provide for tests of the public not
joe's that's nice that's nice
responsibility
sighs responsibilities so hey imagine
being upset by this yeah it's a
non-event it's like honestly no one
successful who's upset about them just
can't get it together take care of
yourself
yeah some people just need something to
be upset about that's not what it is
okay so rapper blue face on Saturday he
broke social distancing by having a
bunch of women in his house to shoot a
music video and he was updating his IG
story with what was going on and two
fights broke out that kept people
thoroughly at rivers strippers music
video girls so I seemed classy keep
going down mm-hmm was it take guys yet
they were not fighting over me it was a
lot of Hannah mixed with Ali attitude a
little lol - I have not had relations
than any of these women no no I was
being racist more than half the people
here was black so if you believe that
you're too invested in the internet a
little too much people thought that
there's racist comments Gil oh yeah
there were a lot of different conspiracy
theories the truth isn't fun
so conspiracy theories making life way
more info yeah people came out there
saying that uh oh there was another
fight with two other women where one
woman was talking to blue face another
woman came from behind and snatched her
wig off we have video of that apparently
you guys take it out but the that's the
one that people had conspiracy theory
over saying that the girl who snatched
the other woman's wig was being racist
anger bald get this black [ __ ] out of
my out of the house or whatever and
blue-faced had to come out and say it
had nothing to do with that but the
girls were getting a little rowdy yeah
sounds like it cool [ __ ] be crazy
dude I'm assuming this was in LA yes
good there's a good choices being made
he posters said no but yeah people were
just thoroughly entertained that
Blueface decided to put all of this up
on his Instagram that's interesting okay
well we're talking about it yeah the
name is blue face yeah I'm gonna have a
heart attack but yeah from the noodle
it's hard to hit you mortal oh that's
easy
I'll keep eating them too I'll keep
eating them cuz I can't stop once I
start come on it's like Philemon
achiever like the Fiat that's exactly I
like that you're hot wishes oh yeah
those are the best I'll stop now though
cuz I can't see that's all right Papa's
mouth is red yeah you know it's not when
I start to turn why he's gotta kiss the
old red mouth there's a good blue phase
Red Mountain so on Thursday a man
decided to go kayaking and he ended up
getting stuck on a small island off of
Jamaica Bay and he was only there for 12
hours but he went to an area that was
incredibly isolated that's the reason
why he decided he want to go out to
kayak he knew that he was supposed to
stay inside but that if he was around
anyone he thought it was gonna be okay
for him to go kayaking he got stuck on
his way back his kayak actually began to
sink he swam back to shore found a
lighter and a bunch of sticks and
spelled out the word help and set them
on fire luckily somebody found it and
people actually came to rescue him I
mean turns curled at times he's really
out looking for people is that Bigfoot
like that might be infrared camera
that's how it looks like he helped when
I just do a lot of rescue search and
rescue we used infrared cameras oh well
we see was saved yeah yep
there yes I'd still rather be at blue
faces party though okay so this man
broke into a restaurant in New Haven
Connecticut and he stayed there for
about
four days just helping himself to
whatever he wanted food wine your
homeless guy well no he's not homeless
he's a dumb dude he just wanted to feel
the vibe of a restaurant ah I can relate
to this but the reason why he got caught
is because the manager of that
restaurant was due to check in every
couple days to make sure the restaurant
was okay it's currently shut down
because of kovat 19 and when the manager
came in and noticed that somebody has
clearly been there he called the police
I guess the man fled but they later
found him close by to where the
restaurant was with a bottle of their
wine and so that's how he got caught
well at least his left eyes and smaller
than the right one that's cool yeah
sounds like a guy who was down on his
luck and sounds like he's about to freak
out this quarantine you do where [ __ ]
quarantine just wanted to feel that
restaurant when I do what it's that
freaking retro Coronas
I'll break in skipper right now and just
eat just live no homeless I just freak
the [ __ ] out yes
someone sent me this I don't know saying
but it's supposed to be the first
recorded ever street fight in 1901 it's
my color so this isn't real though I
mean the color stuff you know let's see
and this is from a pretty reputable
Instagram account
so I see cool kid I'll tell you right
away
it's not the best those were say huh oh
you know it's just so cold the season so
this guy people had that buddy
dude it's 1901
why are people running if this is real
that's cool that was yeah that was it
though watch that again let me see if we
can still sense this is a fraud they
colored it be a weird thing to fake
though innit
it looks pretty long yeah yeah well you
know fighting what does this look like a
real fight first of all it looks like a
real shitty street fight yeah that looks
real and the other one can fight that
looks about right the other guys just
kicks a hat or something I like the
people laughing yeah that's pretty cool
though yeah yeah this account has like
annoying something followers I think
yeah I think that's true you don't think
it's real no I mean everything else the
poster is real a million followers we
nearly father's doesn't mean make them
real I mean it makes it more legit than
if it had like five followers yeah [ __ ]
Jerry has like millions of followers
yeah who know I don't know either it
faked that looks pretty real man yeah
does it look like a real fight yeah
that's pretty cool
he's a what is he home on from India
he's a bodyguard look at his eyes can
you zoom in on his eyes that dude is
intense it's hot but it's hot he's
always a bodyguard let's see am i
serving in the new some of her as a
regular Sikh always a Sikh holds a Conda
sword in his left a ball and chain flail
whoa God back in the day was cool right
no I am [ __ ] around I smell like [ __ ]
though you know my shower brush your
teeth as much back then anywho the next
one do you guys remember that band
puddle of mud
what was the famous song Tam it was uh
then I thought that uh okay we can't
play music anymore here but I'll just
show you the song ah that's nothing
everybody's like we're having an issue
with the hi to Apple's iTunes cuz
everyone goes oh why can't I search for
a find kidding where it got taken down
we were playing music and II got flash
so when they do that they pull the thing
down until you find out the reason
so it should be back up this week yeah
my turn can suck it I will edit this and
then editor we have to edit all that
that's under the flag all right well
they are they recently sing on this
puddle of mud it says 19 days ago I'm
practicing well check it out it's a
tribute to Nirvana if you remember this
song if you having a heart attack I
don't know what's going on his guitar
knows what's going on yes obviously
saying like something it's not like
somebody is sticking the giving like
putting their fingers in his bag full of
money puts on an absolute clinic of bat
singing that's the poor guy yeah well
wait is this Garth Brooks [ __ ] up no
this is just another I'm not a link on
it on this website but that's that that
was a puddle mod yard best was Garth
Brooks a whole [ __ ] thing on when he
joined Facebook that was incredible so
cringe
I found it late in life I found it I did
yeah
Oh Jay Simpson joined tick-tock all
right all right
why is he joining me it's so crazy I
stays relevant we're talking about I'll
just play this for it I might have to
delete this to really cuz it's a music
interesting yeah he's got to be bored
doing the thing you know can't play golf
can't do anything hold on
71 or something like that probably times
a [ __ ] as it seems that he's got some
money yeah me too all right
last one is what you were talking about
earlier Brendan that documentary not
this Michael Jordan's documentary he
said he walked in on a entire team doing
a cocaine party anchor when he was a
rookie yeah
so I'll just play the carp for you I
can't wait to see this looks good can't
wait the boys doing some cocaine man
girls cocaine weed yeah chicks all the
good stuff that Floyd man with his
entourage in Venice that's what it looks
like ain't there any girls involved with
the Bulls back then he's in Venice
that's what looks a dick bike - ah keep
going keep going
Vegas no look at the God no I was like
down to fish
that's Venice no I don't think so we're
on the beach yep cuz that's the dope go
back chin mm-hmm you gone right there
CNG or G&J although there's no street
lights on the boardwalk did I that's
Santee alley oh that's in downtown
that's close to UM Skid Row
that's what looks like yeah looks like
the really bad oh yeah downtown damn
he's just there with no uh no I was just
a bodyguard I'm sure there's a bodyguard
do you not see the giant black man
behind him holding the Matthews and now
I do he's awesome
you definitely as a lot of boys but
still also there's nobody out that place
is uh crazy though it's just still crazy
yeah
what do you mean Skid Row yeah they're
like they're almost like real zombies
some of them your brother who who is
brother in law who was worked as a
social worker and spent a lot of time
walking down Skid Row and helping people
and he said even the skin row it breaks
up into groups like blacks over here
Latinos over here like it's it human
beings are so tribal even on that level
you know it's crazy I knew that you knew
that yeah no I didn't know live
segregated like that voluntarily oh yeah
whites with whites no no not a Skid Row
I don't know I was a see they were all
they clump together yeah tribes driving
up yep trap it up
well there is best boxer of all time
that it
that is it well Brendon young your
date's fat pig I'm not anywhere and I
really [ __ ] miss it won't open up for
me at spoke and I really do because they
sold the tickets are on sale now I will
100% do that end of June Spokane
Washington come here
I know 100 I'll take you're serious
count me in I'm no I'll do it yeah I'm
gonna be your feature don't notice my
anybody else I'm not we'll do a two-man
show we can bring you know one of you
will have that one of them I'll have
them host somebody cool
or maybe I'll bring Chapelle or
something sure whatever you want I'm
excited yeah and we'll go to Coeur
d'Alene that's my spot we'll see maybe
god I'm gonna do [ __ ] I love coral I've
never been
I have cuz I went there because you told
me I went sweat in the lake yeah they're
great yes so they don't like only talk
about it cuz they think it's gonna blow
up
yeah I understand you from grilling get
mad like it's so great there it's like
don't [ __ ] give it away man well I'm
pretty sure Peter gadiot get up you know
so nice so so nice where I want to
retire
I got a fucked-up haircut there you did
yeah saw Barbara and smokey good biking
out there but there is good bike will
start to thick by bike over there yeah
well I want to be part of this nope I
mean BM mono right remember you can
carry the flag and you this hey guys
know what at the finish line you waved
the flag like this MA and then you get
water for the big boys really
I've only boy I going fetch water yeah
you're the water boy I'm the water boy I
think water I do it in a pail no I got
your water boys don't make me cook up
highs and stuff you cook hula
don't make me cook pies in an apron who
pies yeah don't make me be a bad little
handle bars in granola bars baby boys
your pies are ready hope you don't mind
my apron oops forgot to wear anything
underneath my little buddy what he is
sticking out thick boys what the big
boys dumping you no I would never you
guys better not help me down I'll be so
mad let's eat your apple pie hope you
like it if you don't like it don't
punish me for
it's already put enough cinnamon on the
Apple that hey what the [ __ ] happened oh
Jesus Christ what the [ __ ]
it's a Marc Maron podcast I'm was hey
man Jesus Christ I thank God you got me
out of my game I know they don't warn
teen [ __ ] boys to run some no no no I
just got I got a little cat and a bike
on you leave some leave some tracks huh
I'm better [ __ ] polish your guy's spikes
I'm out of here
butcher my little rattlesnake or what oh
you know we did a rat snake fire stop
them
you guys better not I love you too
Runkle
we spank their butt oh [ __ ] Daisy oh
everybody's in Spanish good news
everybody shaved down again covered in
mineral oil so I'm gonna be real
slippery who wants pie dude we're not
serving pie come on but pie how about
some energy gel ooh
enter divide the shelf oh here it comes
provide the jug of employee yeah it's
old its old it smells like dust I'm
leaving this the van kid grout